bonjour solesmes vous suivez ce
rassemblement le cortège doit s'élancer
d'un instant à l'autre
oui bonjour ce fichier et bien écoutez
le cortège a pris un petit peu de retard
et pour cause un des leaders des gilet
jaune a été interpellé par les crs et il
est actuellement retenu dans un camion
de police il s'agit de jérôme rodriguez
et je suis avec un des témoins de cette
arrestation et bonjour hervé que s'est
il passé
alors c'est simple on arrivait de paris
sur les coups de 13 heures 30
nous avons mangé une petite frite pour
profiter des commerces au local et sur
une terrasse d'un restaurant et on s'est
fait au bout d'un quart d'heure
entourés par une trentaine de policiers
et on a entendu une dame dire on
verbalise tout ce qu'il ya du jaune ils
ont demandé nos pièces d'identité j'ai
donné la mienne je sais pas ce qu'ils
ont fait avec jean m'a demandé si mal et
verbalisé il me dit que non
ils ont demandé à la jérôme jérôme il
avait pas sur lui ou l'ama problème
apparemment donc il a dit m le pire
c'est qu'on lui demande la pièce à
monsieur rodriguez donc ils savaient
qu'ils savaient qu'ils étaient monsieur
rodriguez mais bon je pense qu'il a ses
fichiers déjà il sait contrôler tous les
cinq minutes il peut pas se déplacer
tranquillement
voilà donc voila mon retour de cette
expérience
triste triste expérience acquise on est
tenté de contrôler son identité puis ils
l'ont interpellé
oui tout à fait il s'est laissé faire
ils lui ont dit on va vous emmener au
poste pour une vérification d'identité
et donc voilà il s'est laissé faire il a
attendu ses mains que ce que voulez
qu'il fasse
et puis voilà ils ont pris l'ont jeté
comme un comme un sac de pommes de terre
dans le camion de police
et voilà merci un vie je me trouve
également avec david libeskind a évoqué
des gilet jaune bonjour monsieur comment
vous interpréter cette arrestation
pour jérôme malheureusement ça continue
puisque il avait déjà été
alors il n'avait pas été arrêté à paris
mille en avait six interpellés parce
qu'il avait refusé de montrer sa carte
d'identité
là on est exactement dans la même
situation sauf que là il était en train
de il était en terrasse en train de
déjeuner avec des camarades qu'il
n'avait aucun signe distinctif de gilet
jaune et ce fonds permet en fait de
contrôler l'identité de toutes les
personnes qui étaient sur la terrasse
jérôme rodriguez d'après les témoignages
que j'ai pu avoir a été agacé ce qui est
parfaitement normal puisque lui en fait
on le contrôle systématiquement décliné
dans la rue samedi toutes les cinq
minutes
moi même j'ai pu j'ai pu le voir j'ai pu
constater donc là en fait je ne sais pas
ce qui leur a répondu mais il n'a pas
voulu montrer sa carte d'identité mais
de façon correcte il s'est pas rebellé
et ils l'ont embarqué ou à l'agglo
embarqués au commissariat
alors qu'est ce qui va lui arriver ils
peuvent leur retenir quatre heures pour
sans contrôle d'identité mais là et
toute façon il va montrer sa carte
d'identité donc il devrait être là s'en
sortir dans les prochaines minutes
on a pu avoir
admis camarades a pu avoir l'un des
commandants de police voilà on a essayé
de négocier avec lui et le commandant de
police nous a dit de façon qu'ils
allaient bientôt sortir donc pas de
panique
mais voilà pour jérôme depuis un moment
déjà les jaunes sa vie c'est ce à quoi
les tout le temps à redhill et tout en
contrôle et le samedi
il reçoit en permanence des des menaces
par par mail par messenger quoi mais bon
mais bon il lâche rien il est déterminé
donc de toutes façons il continuera sur
sa ligne de conduite et c'est pas ce
type d'arrestation a fait qui va le
décourager la manifestation a pris aussi
un peu de retard parce que fait qu'à la
dernière minute vous étiez encore en
pourparlers avec la préfecture
concernant le trajet est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire pourquoi ce trajet
poser problème
alors en fait le trajet posait pas de
problème moi j'étais l'avocat des
organisateurs des déclarants notamment
charlène et corinne et donc ses
organisateurs avaient proposé enfin
avait proposé avait déclaré un parcours
la préfecture a répondu et a modifié le
parcours initial le parcours initial
devait faire trois heures sur je crois à
8 km et la préfecture s'est permis de
son propre chef à leur proposer enfin à
leur imposer un parcours d'une heure qui
faisait trois à quatre kilomètres ce qui
est formellement interdit par la loi
parce que si la préfecture n'étaient pas
d'accord avec le parcours initial elle
aurait dû en fait émettre un arrêté
préfectoral d'interdiction de la
manifestation ce qui n'a pas été du tout
le cas donc le préfet le préfet du nord
en fait a commis des actes attentatoires
à la liberté de circuler de manifester
puisque la actuellement le parcours
construit si le parcours imposé par la
préfecture et non déclarés par les
déclarants alors que cette manifestation
a été autorisé puisqu'il n'y avait pas
d'instinct d'arrêtés d'interdiction
sa chambre pour compléter sachant que le
parcours initial ne prévoyait pas de
passer en centre ville puisqu'il y avait
quand même un arrêté qui interdisait le
centre-ville de ligne voilà donc les
organisateurs étaient dans leur bon
droit dans leur légalité quoi merci
beaucoup monsieur libeskind donc cette
manifestation va se poursuivre a priori
jusqu'à à 17h30 et vous l'aurez compris
sur un trajet qui est désormais détourné
et qui n'est plus le trajet initial
selon godard depuis lille merci beaucoup
solesmes